it needs a sofa of actors so and are
there kind of any I wouldn't bed tricks
but are there any shortcuts into playing
a great ape a great eye well well well
Quadra petting is a large part of it
okay so quad depending is walking on all
fours and I happen to have with me some
some arm extensions which we could that
we could all ever go with alright and
these in fact are how we called you fit
so we can all have a go and I think I
think we should would you have done no
not yet well let me just show you so
these are these are looking it's got
like Martians motion-capture dots on it
already so we can shoot and so anyway so
you so let me just a good place to
standing yeah wicked where wherever
wherever you want to go yeah so first of
all you know if you're going to get into
into being in a lucky like them your
silverback gorilla then you tend to have
you
that's a spitting out if your if your
chimpanzee then yet then you're tucked
in like this so you can choose between a
gorilla or or two okay whichever you
like yes all you normally write off the
bottom inside then you stop all the back
like that and then we're going to do
this okay so the name of andronica
country very slippery shoes on
so column method actor for a role in the
net asset oh by the way wrestler see you
watch you're going to be so good at this
you're gonna be so good at this I'm glad
I wore such tight trousers how do you
beat your chest receipt so hang on
[Applause]
what did you think your frenzied way
that was you sort of added the skin
succulent even carry me over you do a
wolf as a chimp
[Applause]
[Music]